What we're doing is trying to take mutations
in different genes and combine them together
to understand how genes work together to coordinate
cell life.
And we do this in a simple organism like yeast
that only has 6,000 genes.
But remarkably yeast is very similar to humans
so it provides a very good model to understand.
What we learn in yeast can provide us with
some direction or a reference to understand
— to help us understand how genes work together
to help modulate central functions and life
in human cells.
So what we do is take a collection of yeast
strains, each of which is deleted for a different
gene or mutated for a different gene, and
we use a technology we developed in our lab
that allows us to combine pairs of mutations
in the same cell.
And then we can simply ask: Do the mutations
in these pairs of genes allow the cell to
live or not?
And we use robotic technologies to do this
and we were able to test all 18 million possible
mutant combinations.
And we don't think that genes work in isolation.
So there are obviously many examples of Mendelian
diseases where a single cell mutation in a
single gene results in a disease.
So those cases would be highly predictive.
We think that many common diseases are affected
by combinations of mutations, rare mutations
in different genes.
What we've done is tested all possible double
mutant combinations to build this large network.
And we see many structures in these networks
that we think can provide a reference from
which we start to learn rules and principles
that might help us to understand or simplify
the problem in humans and help us develop
rules for how different genes interact.
We believe this will hep us simplify the problem
or at least provide a guide to start to understand
how genes work together to modify complex
disease in humans.